dpa sport könnten diese will video
erstellen heutigen video instagram wer
von youtube nach dem zkb dem fenster
raus auf jeden fall verdient
nachgestellt werden wären dafür heute
max im team wir haben jahre ein team wie
diagnosen hiermit lässt die schöne aus
dem blut deswegen fange mit diesem
wunderbaren weg von den scope anja wir
erstmal vor der geplanten vernichtung
mal dass er nie die besitzer art
director geben muss darauf achten dass
ich das bild auch direkt abbilden
es war ja für sein erstes tor ein und
griffen sich dadurch nicht ist und wer
wirklich probleme könnte längere fahrt
muss erstmal hier den blick dir
anschauen perfekt ok ich würde erstmal
so trocken
okay wir ein bisschen leckeres käufer
als auch und ein bisschen weniger wir in
deutschland ja jetzt machst du das
[Musik]
normalerweise eher weniger okay wir
machen direkt weiter mit
zum bild versteckt leute deswegen würde
ich dann nehme als nächstes ein bild was
man braucht und zwar dass hier erklärst
du dich behalten die kamera die alle
also wir wollen nicht nachstellen und
hält jetzt auch creative director wo
muss man muss den kopf hinhalten
[Musik]
war der auslöser der bestätigt dass
dietrich nachgestellt wurde
da können wir auch gemeistert leute sehr
erfolgreich gewinn machen wir zweiter
mit diesem bild für das was aber
rausgehen auto passt auch oder auch das
habe erfolgreich gemeistert was
natürlich logischerweise bedeutet dass
wir jetzt zu diesem bild übergehen
das riecht ja da brauchen wir
wahrscheinlich wieder ja wenn er
möglichkeit das muss ich auf den rücken
du kannst für die oben drauf sein wird
es nur herum
was müsste sagen ist ein gutes bild
nachzustellen auf der straße alles
klappt müssen die rechte antwort auf
gestützt auf dem wohl ein bisschen
weiter hinten sind beide bisschen weiter
hinten ist diese strecke zur kamera
zeigen knie und linken ist das dual
stack betrieb einfach nur gut verstehen
keine hände sind an den oberschenkeln
diese werde eine kreuzung oder click
wacklig sein fuß weiter hoch fuß weiter
jedes jahr auch wieder komplett skaliert
nach zehn jahren hier oben könne man
kann die komplette video hier gibt der
neuesten folge vermochten die medien
gerne abschwächen